major news from Bernie Sanders yesterday
he went on CNN State of the Union in the
wake of yet another embarrassing failure
by Republicans to repeal Obamacare
Bernie Sanders is saying he will be
introducing a single-payer health care
bill in the Senate here he is explaining
it to Jake Tapper we're going to
introduce a single-payer health care
plan literally as soon as we're through
with the Republican health care debate
it seems like we're through and the
Obamacare repeal effort has collapsed
are you going to introduce single-payer
absolutely of course we are we're just
you know we're tweaking the final points
of the bill and we're figuring out how
we can mount a national campaign to
bring people together here's where we
are Jake and it's important for
Americans to understand this please we
are the only major country on earth the
only one not to guarantee health care to
all people the result is 28 million
people who are uninsured millions of
people who are paying deductibles and
co-payments that are far too high and if
the Republicans had gotten their way
they would vote another 30 or 32 million
people thrown off of health insurance
it's great to introduce a bill
particularly one that I agree with I do
have to break it to Bernie and to
everybody else that introducing a bill
is very different than the Democratic
Party taking on single-payer health care
or Medicare for all as part of their
platform case in point
House Democrats have been introducing
some version of this past January HR 676
Medicare for all bill for a long time
and it is barely a blip on any radar you
might know about it from independent
news sources I've been talking about it
but it's a non-starter because no
significant portion of the Democratic
Party is united behind it now this will
be some kind of a medicare-for-all
proposal some people don't get why
that's an attractive path versus a new
single-payer system the general idea is
we have Medicare already so you've got
the infrastructure in place all you do
is change the age requirement right you
say instead of having to be 65 you can
be 0 and be part of the Medicare system
and then you separately pass legislation
for its funding as a general thing when
you adapt an existing system
it's simpler faster and less expensive
than creating a brand new system you
could probably get this done
the legislation could be done in weeks
nevermind months a new system would take
a very very long time I support this but
it is mostly a non-starter although I
say cheers to Bernie Sanders and I hope
it gets more attention it's certainly
not going to pass with Republicans
controlling the House Senate and the
White House but the most powerful thing
that Democrats could do is make this a
part of the platform make it a part of
the official platform and campaign on
this it's obviously not going to pass
but what I think the good that is that
would come out of this would be you get
some of those Democrats on record
because a lot of them are running away
from this issue they don't want to speak
on if they support Medicare for all or
not and now it will be up to a vote
people are going to know where they
stand on it that's the biggest advantage
of this right which is we will be
potentially able to get if and remember
just introducing a bill doesn't mean
that you will ultimately have a vote on
it we've got a lot of steps here but you
could potentially get Senate Democrats
on the record who don't support this
it's not going to pass right we know
it's not going to pass under the current
House and Senate control by Republicans
and Donald Trump in the White House so
therefore this is a good opportunity for
Democrats who want this to vote yes in
order to be able to tout their I
supported Medicare for all credentials
to their constituents if you still vote
no on a totally safe vote in the sense
that it will never actually pass then
you really must not want this and many
corporate Democrats probably don't want
this because the insurance industry we
talk about here's issues where
Republicans and Democrats are very
similar and here's issues with
Republicans and Democrats are very
different the funding from health
insurance companies is pretty ubiquitous
and widespread and this could be really
useful in figuring out who's actually on
the side of this among the Democrats I
do have to play devil's advocate here
though because it does sound a little
bit to me like Republicans voting to
repeal Obamacare 61 times and spending
millions of dollars on it knowing that
Obama himself would veto the bill yeah
is this a little bit of the same thing
it's a fair criticism in that it's not
going to pass
so the value of introducing the bill is
pretty limited other than for Bernie
Sanders is saying I support this that's
exactly why I think the value is make it
part of the Democratic platform Medicare
for all it's a strong position and
negotiate from that as opposed to as
I've said many times Obama's public
option would be kind of nice oh no okay
then we'll get rid of it and that
doesn't mean Obamacare didn't do some
good things
it certainly doesn't change the reality
that Obamacare reinforced the employer
connected for-profit insurance system
that we have but putting that aside make
this your platform Democrats already
many people discussing this on our
reddit discussion forum where nearly
4,000 of our viewers and listeners are
regularly discussing politics go to
david pakman.com slash reddit
join the discussion I'm thrilled that
today's program is supported by taga dab
the hosting specialists offering
whatever type of hosting package is good
for your business or project this
includes dedicated and virtual private
server solutions cloud server options
which are increasingly popular as well
as custom server solutions taga dabs web
hosting services support a really broad
range of customers and businesses around
the world and this includes bloggers
tech startups traders and finance gamers
web developers really whatever you can
think of and you can scale their cloud
servers up or down to meet the
particular needs of your business and to
also cut costs by only paying for what
you use you can save twenty British
pounds a little over twenty US dollars
on cloud server options by going to
signup tag adapt calm /td PS and using
the coupon code TDPS
20 that's sign up ta ga da be calm /td
PS the discount code all one word all
lowercase TD PS 20 check it out